what is the definition or the praxeology
if you will of a high value man and you
just described yourself as a high value
man so i assume you've done your
research on this so if you guys would
just take a second define what this high
value man hvm i turn it i've heard
multiple times
explain that please i think objectively
speaking it's a confluence of muddy
muscles and game right it's it's
maximizing your put i think a high value
man is the guy who maximizes his
personal potential and does it in such a
time and then utilizes that that
potential okay so
a lot of like i mean you know talking
about kevin sams and everything those
are prescriptions i deal with
descriptions that's why i said a lot of
the stuff that like all these guys who
are out here doing this stuff i'm not
claiming to be like the only source in
the manosphere that has this stuff but
it's like a lot of that stuff is
derivative from my work okay well you'll
constantly hear that he wrote the bible
of the man exactly so my but again my
my books are written from the position
of their being objective
doing my death my best stab at
objectivity that's number one number two
is that it's not a prescription but that
doesn't mean that people won't take that
work and turn it into prescriptions
that's what tate does that's what kevin
samuels does that's what when you use
the word
should
that's when that's when it ceases to be
about what is and what you should do so
i don't deal in shoulds i deal an is
should men spin plates and date as many
women as they can now exclusively and
increase their body count okay so is it
about body count that's the other thing
okay so here's the thing is if you read
those six chapters you'll also notice
that the end of that of the sixth
chapter is transitioning from
non-exclusive dating to becoming
monogamous with someone so what my my if
that if you're going to take that so you
prescribe money if that's going to be
what i'm saying is that most guys want
to get into that okay i know guys like
george gammon i know
yourself i know a lot of guys who don't
want anything to do with monogamy and
they're they're still high value men
because they've they've maximized money
muscles and game right they have chosen
as a lifestyle not to be monogamous and
maybe they don't want to have children
but they're still doing very very well
for themselves so is that high value or
is a high value man the guy who is like
like roller tomassie he's been married
for 26 years he's got a beautiful
daughter he makes a good chunk of change
he's in an ideal marriage is that high
value or is it high value is tate high
value i would say all of the above it
just depends on what their lifestyle
choices are and what it is that they
choose to do so if you're gonna if
you're gonna idealize uh the lifestyle
of andrew tate and say he's on his
hustle like i saw the the interview with
you and pat yesterday and i'm like well
that's very very interesting considering
the lifestyle that andrew tate and and
tristan also um are leave are living
right now and if they're going to
profess to be orthodox christians and
where is their kids where's their thing
if that's if that is that the benchmark
is that the goal state right because
your goal state which would probably be
uh get into a marriage have kids and and
love god with all your heart and all
your mind right so that would be a high
value man for other guys
being a high value man they still have
all of those things that tate has but
they don't have like they don't have
family they don't have they're not
married they don't have a you know
golden retriever in the yard so what
that's why i'm saying the old order 20th
century ideal for what is a high value
man throw that out the window we are
still clinging to old order ideals in a
21st century that says well here's the
data sets right now we have more access
to more information right now that
completely crush all of our wants to
cling onto this romantic idea of the
20th century of the 18th century
whatever century because we think that
that ought to be how we do things and in
some ways for some guys for for you and
me that works really well for us but for
andrew tape people will say you're a
beta and i'm a beta and we're blue pill
because we're married and we've been
married for so long so why what that's
why i said like when guys come at me and
they say oh he can't be red pill because
he's married he can't speak
knowledgeably because he's been married
for 26 years they don't know anything
about my history they don't know
anything about like my like what it is
that
allows me to speak authoritatively about
this kind of stuff they have they throw
that out the window because you're
married and also on the opposite side if
you're not married if you're if you're a
guy like andrew tate living the best
life you're living up to your potential
but you don't have kids and you haven't
done anything like with your life
because you're not married and you don't
have a dog in the yard kind of thing
then you're actually the beta because
you're not you know uh living up to your
full potential by not having you know by
not having kids and everything so it
just depends on whose definition that
we're working well one of the questions
that we always ask and would pat always
ask it's always who do you want to be
right who do you want to establish that
most men want children
yes how do you feel about how do you go
about it you go about how you let me
write this content and i want to get
your definition of a high value men we
asked our audience we appreciate you
guys valuetainers out there everyone who
came from russon's channel everyone came
from rollo's channel rational mail uh if
you're if you're a believer of what's
known as the pareto principle the 80 20
rule it's essentially what the uh
numbers show 78 of you guys say that
they are not waiting
uh for marriage to have sex and 22
percent so almost 80 20 saying no yeah
i'll wait for seven and sometimes
10 of that 20 are insults to begin with
bang bang guys get out of the house bang
bang define high define high value man
and then we'll move on to the next time
i think it's probably connected to
income influence what you can do your
network so on a sofa money muscle's game
that he talks about and then
yeah i think i think that's fair and i
think if we're talking about spinning
plates my issue with that is is how
do men
sacrifice the opportunity cost of
spinning plates dating all these women
non-exclusively right when if we're
talking about hey man uh what should you
be doing in your 20s what should you be
doing in your late teens
i think we would say hey develop some
useful skills develop some scarce skills
develop your soft skills fall on your
ass a lot
make some mistakes do something and i
think it's it's an incoherent logic to
say hey go date as many women as you can
non-exclusively
at what expense
when you could be developing yourself
becoming
the man to the high value mana you hear
this thing with the six six six man six
foot tall six figures six foot right
okay everybody's not going to be that
what can we sauce can we get some of
these guys to be two out of three
right if a guy comes to you and he says
hey man i'm making 40 grand i'm making
50 grand can we get him to 100 right if
he's fat can we get him to eat less
calories can we get him can we get them
shredded and again i know you're like
well these are prescriptions but i'm
like man there are prescriptions and
life works a specific way if i want to
get cut and shredded which i'm doing
right now i have to stop eating junk
food high caloric food and i have to eat
more high nutrient high volume food get
my protein get my macros due to compound
lips i don't understand why this isn't
directly transferable this philosophy
transferable to ending up in a high
marriage so you're like most men are
going to uh sleep around and do whatever
and i'm like yeah and most people are
fat rob you know 70 percent more than
that 75 30 40 are obese most people are
like most people i understand right but
what i'm saying is if we're leading men
and i'm and we're saying hey
how do we get more money and you're like
dude that's what you got to do you got
to work on this hey how do you man
you've been married 26 years how did you
guys do that somebody asked me we went
to marriage conferences we read a ton of
books we educated ourselves we got
pre-marital counseling we had the hard
conversations we dispelled the soul mate
myth i'm with you there 100 the
idealistic romantic nonsensical disney
love of marriage we establish all that
stuff ahead of time so that's the part
where i go i look at i look at some of
the stuff i'm like why are we not
talking about what actually requires to
get someone like a sauce to land in a
place of man i'm in a happy monogamous
marriage where kids and family can
thrive which is why i wrote the fourth i
also think let me just wait this this is
the fourth book that's the fourth yeah
that's the how does that no this is the
first book just a fourth okay so i wrote
the fourth book to to to address
all the guys who would tell me exactly
what you're saying well rolo i bel i i
understand what you're saying i get all
this about the red pill i get all this
stuff i i'm 100 on board with you my
religious convictions are i don't want
to have sex before marriage my religious
convictions are i'm a muslim i'm a jew i
i i interviewed that took three years to
write that book that's the longest i
ever took to write a book because i had
to be bulletproof everybody heard i was
writing a book about religion yeah about
everybody heard overall is writing a
book about the red pill in religion i
had like people coming out of the
woodwork oh you're going to talk about
the amish and and are you going to talk
about mormons are going to talk about
you know the eastern orthodox christian
church of 1865 and like i had to be on
my game to understand all that stuff so
it took a long time to do that but what
i do in that book is i make the
comparison say look there are st like
people will would told me this they said
well uh islam is actually the red pill
religion christianity is the red pill
religion everyone mormon
judaism is the red pill of religion
here's and there are then they were
right about certain parts of it they're
like this is why this was a thing
because they understood the differences
between men and women they understood
intersectional dynamics in a way that we
have lost since the sexual revolution so
coming back to that and making it a a
point of like here's the the latent
purpose behind these traditions like i
make the point in here where it's like
there are prohibitions against eating
shellfish or or eating like ham or
something like that you're not supposed
to eat a clove in the ant you know thing
because in judaism you can't have a
cheeseburger you can't have a meat
exactly because because
because back in the day you could get
trichognosis and die from that so what
are we going to tell everybody god said
don't have ham so if you like that clip
click right here to watch another or if
you want to watch the entire sauce cast
click right here
[Music]